- Noël
C'est ce que laissent présager
les cabanes désertées du célèbre
marché de Noë V V Vienne.
Les , , , , , , , , , , , , , ,s
lumières festives s'éteignent
pour au moins trois semaines.De,
les échoppes qui proposent
artisanat, produit t t terroir
et autres plaisirs ont dû,
comme la plupart des commerces
du pays, fermer leurs volets.
Anna travaille ici depuis
une douzaine d'année.uvuvuvuvuvs
elle en veut à ceux qui refusent
encore de se faire vaccine
"Je ne pense qu'on ne doit pas
s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s,
dit-elle, mais il faut
aussi assumer un peu de
responsabilité. La plupart des
gens croient que le coronavirus
va disparaître d'un coup, comme
ça, mais c
Je pense qu'il faut faire
preuve de responsabilité."
En annonçant la fermeture
forcée des restaurants,
des boutiques et des lieux
p p p p p p p p p p p p p p p u
pour bien des dirigeants
européens : la vaccination
obligatoire pour tous.
Le Parleme
pour forcer tous les Autrichiens
adultes à se faire vaccineranan.
Katharina est venue poure e e en
Pfizer à contrecoeur,
se méfiant toujours
des vaccins de type ARN.
"Je ne suis pas vr
ARN, dit-elle. Je ne sais pas
si c'est une bonne chose, mais
je r r r r résignée, en fait,
c'est la vérité."
(cris et pleurs)
Helga, 5 ans, est tout aussi
contrariée. Mais sa mère
est soul
elle aussi recevoir
la protectioououououout
son entourage bénéficie.Depuis ,
l'Autriche vaccine
les enfant 11 ans.
Le suçon qu'elle a reçu
en cadeau ne console pteteteteta
recevoir une deuxième dose
dans trois semaines.
"Malheureusement, soupiretrtrtrs
les vaccins qu'elle a reçus
comme il se doit pour
les enfants, nous lui ex
nous protégeons sa santé et que,
si elle devrait être malade,
elle nt t t t t t pas
gravement."onononononononononons
les centres de vaccination
est une très bonne
disent les responsables,
l'obligation vaccinale en
février prochain, c'est trop
ta
"Si nous avions rendu
la vaccination obligatoire
t partout en Europe,
dit cette médecin,
nous n'aurions peut-être pas
de quatrième vague. Je cvovovove
que l'Europe va nous suivre."
Les nouvelles mesures sa
dérangent, surtout à l'extrême
droite de l'échiquier politique
qui dénonce une dictature
sanita0000000000000000000000000t
défilé dans les rues de Vienne
pour exprimer leur colère.
"Nous avons en Autriche
un parti , le FPÖ,
qui s'oppose cla
à la vaccination obligatoire,
dit cette analyste, qui f f f f.
C'est un parti qui recommande
par exemple le
comme médicaments contre
le virus, où les gens
se sont déjà retrouvés dans
à cause d'un empoisonnement.
20 et 25 % d'appuis."
Si l'Autriche n'a plus le choix
que d'imposer la vaccination,
le confinement généralueueueueu,
selon ce député membre du parti
le plus immemememememememement.
"Nous pensons que c'est
trop tôt, dit-il. Ce sontdededee
où il y a de très forts taux de
contamination. Ils ont fait trop
d'erreurs. Mais
doit être confiné."memememememet
ce qu'il avait promis de ne pas
faire", dit-il, so
cette fois, il tiendra parole
et que le confinement sera
levé à temps pour profiter
Ici Marie-Ève Bédard,
Radio-Canada, Vienn